nous pouvons alors influencer le niveau de changement climatique à venir
auquel nous aurons à nous adapter.
Nous avons donc le choix.
Nous pouvons choisir de prendre au sérieux le changement climatique,
ce qui implique de réduire sensiblement nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
et nous devrons alors nous adapter à moins de conséquences négatives dans le futur.
À l'inverse, on peut continuer à ignorer le problème du changement climatique.
Mais dans ce cas, nous choisissons
de nous adapter à des conséquences bien plus importantes dans le futur.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
En tant qu'habitants de pays dont les émissions par tête sont élevées,
nous faisons ce choix pour les autres également.
Mais le choix que nous n'avons pas
est celui d'un avenir sans changement climatique.
Au cours des vingt dernières années,
les négociateurs et les responsables de nos gouvernements se sont réunis
pour discuter du changement climatique.
Et ils se sont concentrés sur la façon d'éviter un réchauffement
qui dépasserait de 2°C les niveaux pré-industriels.
Il s'agit de la température associée à des impacts dangereux,
mesurés par divers indicateurs,
pour les hommes et pour l'environnement.
Ces 2°C représentent donc un niveau dangereux de changement climatique.
Mais cette dangerosité peut être subjective.
Si l'on pense à un événement météo extrême
qui pourrait se produire dans le monde,
et s'il survient dans une partie du monde qui dispose de bonnes infrastructures,
où la population est bien assurée, etc.,
cet impact peut être déstabilisant,
il peut être bouleversant et entraîner des coûts.
Il peut même faire des victimes.
Mais si ce même événement se produit dans une partie du monde
où les infrastructures sont médiocres,
où la population n'est pas bien assurée,
ou n'a pas accès à des réseaux de solidarité,
ce même impact du changement climatique peut alors s'avérer dévastateur.
Il peut entraîner la destruction d'un grand nombre de logements,
mais il peut aussi causer la mort de nombreuses personnes.
Voici un graphique des émissions de CO2
dues à l'industrie et aux énergies fossiles
depuis la période précédant la révolution industrielle
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Et ce que l'on remarque immédiatement,
c'est que les émissions ont augmenté de façon exponentielle.
Prenons une période de temps plus courte, celle à partir de 1950.
Nous avons mis en place en 1988
le panel inter-gourvernemental sur le changement climatique,
le Sommet de la Terre à Rio en 1992,
et plusieurs années après, en 2009, l'accord de Copenhague,
où il a été convenu d'éviter une hausse des températures de 2°C
conformément à la science et en s'appuyant sur le principe d'équité.
Et en 2012, il y a eu la conférence Rio+20.
Et tout au long de ces conférences,
et beaucoup d'autres encore,
les émissions ont continué à augmenter.
Si l'on regarde la tendance de nos émissions durant ces dernières années,
et qu'on ajoute à cela
la tendance des déplacements dans l'économie mondiale,
nous sommes davantage sur la voie
d'un réchauffement climatique de 4°C
que d'un réchauffement de 2°C.
Maintenant, prenons un moment
pour réfléchir à cette hausse moyenne de 4°C.
Une grande partie de la planète est recouverte par la mer.
La mer ayant une inertie thermique supérieure à celle des terres,
les températures moyennes dans les terres seront donc supérieures
à celles de la mer.
Par ailleurs, en tant qu'êtres humains, nous ne ressentons pas
la température moyenne.
Nous sentons quand il fait chaud, quand il fait froid,
quand il pleut, surtout si vous vivez comme moi à Manchester.
Alors imaginez-vous maintenant dans une ville.
Quelque part dans le monde :
Mumbaï, Pékin, New York, Londres.
C'est le jour le plus chaud que vous avez vécu.
Le soleil est brûlant,
il y a du béton et du verre tout autour de vous.
Maintenant, imaginez cette situation
avec six, huit, peut-être même dix à douze degrés de plus
en ce jour de canicule.
C'est ce genre de choses que nous allons vivre
avec le scénario d'une température moyenne mondiale de 4°C.
Le problème avec de tels extrêmes,
pas seulement pour la température,
mais aussi en termes de tempêtes et autres conséquences climatiques,
c'est que nos infrastructures ne sont pas prévues pour ces événements.
Nos routes et nos chemins de fer
ont été conçus pour du long terme
et uniquement pour un nombre limité d'impacts
dans chaque partie du monde.
Ces infrastructures vont être mises à rude épreuve.
Nos centrales électriques doivent être refroidies avec de l'eau
jusqu'à une certaine température pour rester efficaces et résistantes.
Nos bâtiments sont conçus pour être confortables
et adaptés à une certaine fourchette de températures.
Tout cela va être remis en question
avec un scénario retenant l'hypothèse des 4°C.
Nos infrastructures n'ont pas été conçues pour faire face à cela.
Pour revenir en arrière, et en ayant à l'esprit ces 4°C,
il ne s'agit pas seulement d'impacts directs,
mais aussi d'impacts indirects.
Prenons par exemple la sécurité alimentaire.
Les récoltes de maïs et de blé
dans certaines parties du monde
seront jusqu'à 40% plus faibles
dans le cas d'un scénario de 4°C,
et celles de riz jusqu'à 30% plus faibles.
C'est absolument dévastateur en termes de sécurité alimentaire.
En fin de compte, les impacts que l'on peut anticiper
avec ce scénario de 4°C
seront incompatibles avec la façon dont la vie est organisée sur Terre.
Revenons à nos trajectoires et à nos graphiques de 2°C et 4°C.
Est-il encore raisonnable de considérer la trajectoire de 2°C ?
Nombre de mes collègues et d'autres scientifiques
diraient qu'il est déjà trop tard pour éviter un réchauffement de 2°C.
Mais j'aimerais m'appuyer sur mes recherches
sur les systèmes énergétiques et alimentaires,
sur l'aviation et le transport maritime,
pour dire que, selon moi, il y a encore quelques chances
d'éviter ce dangereux changement climatique de 2°C.
Mais nous devons nous intéresser aux chiffres
pour savoir comment faire.
Si l'on regarde cette trajectoire et ces graphiques,
le cercle jaune met en évidence le fait que le départ
de la courbe rouge de 4°C
vers la courbe verte de 2°C est imminent.
Et cela est dû aux émissions cumulatives,
ou budget carbone.
En d'autres termes, à cause des lumières et des projecteurs
qui sont aujourd'hui dans cette salle,
le CO2 rejeté dans l'atmosphère
en raison de cette consommation d'électricité
restera très longtemps.
Une partie restera dans l'atmosphère pendant un siècle, voire plus.
Il s'accumulera, car les gaz à effet de serre ont tendance à s'accumuler.
Cela révèle quelque chose sur ces trajectoires.
D'abord, cela révèle que c'est la zone située sous la courbe qui importe le plus,
et non l'endroit que nous atteindrons à telle ou telle date.
C'est très important, parce que peu importe
que nous développions une super technologie
pour résoudre notre problème énergétique à la veille de l'année 2050,
juste à temps pour tout arranger.
Parce que dans le même temps, les émissions se seront accumulées.
Si l'on continue dans cette voie d'un scénario de 4°C représenté en rouge,
la durée durant laquelle on le poursuivra
devra être compensée dans les années à venir
pour conserver le même budget carbone, et la même surface située sous la courbe.
Ce qui veut dire que cette trajectoire, représentée en rouge, devient plus raide.
En d'autres termes, si l'on ne réduit pas nos émissions à court et moyen terme,
nous devrons réduire nos émissions plus drastiquement d'une année à l'autre.
Nous devons aussi réduire l'empreinte carbone
de notre système énergétique.
Mais si nous ne commençons pas à réduire ces émissions à court et moyen terme,
nous aurons à le faire encore plus rapidement.
C'est un défi de taille pour nous.
Et cela révèle aussi quelque chose de notre politique énergétique.
Si vous vivez dans une partie du monde
où les émissions par habitant sont élevées,
cela indique qu'il faut réduire la demande en énergie.
Parce que même avec la meilleure volonté du monde,
les infrastructures techniques de grande échelle
que nous avons besoin de déployer
pour réduire l'empreinte carbone du côté de l'offre énergétique
ne seront simplement pas disponibles à temps.
Peu importe finalement que l'on choisisse le nucléaire
ou le captage et stockage de carbone,
que l'on améliore la production de biocarburants,
ou que l'on décide de développer l'énergie éolienne et hydraulique.
Tout cela prend du temps.
Puisque c'est la surface sous la courbe qui compte,
on doit mettre l'accent sur l'efficacité énergétique,
mais aussi sur l'économie d'énergie, c'est-à-dire consommer moins d'énergie.
Faire cela implique également
que tout en continuant à déployer la technologie sur le plan de l'offre,
nous aurons moins d'efforts à faire si nous parvenons
à réduire notre consommation d'énergie,
parce qu'on aura alors besoin de moins d'infrastructures.
Un autre problème auquel nous devons nous confronter
est celui du bien-être et de l'équité.
Beaucoup de pays dans le monde ont besoin d'élever leur niveau de vie.
Mais puisque les systèmes énergétiques actuels reposent sur l'énergie fossile,
la croissance de ces économies entraîne une hausse des émissions.
Si nous sommes maintenant tous contraints par le même budget carbone,
et que certains pays du monde ont besoin d'augmenter leurs émissions,
cela implique que les émissions des autres pays doivent être réduites.
Il y a là de véritables défis à relever pour les pays riches.
Car d'après nos recherches,
si vous êtes dans un pays
où les émissions par habitant sont élevées,
c'est-à-dire en Amérique du Nord, en Europe, en Australie,
il faudra une réduction des émissions de l'ordre de 10% par an,
dès maintenant,
pour avoir des chances d'éviter la perspective des 2°C.
Replaçons cela dans son contexte.
L'économiste Nicholas Stern
affirmait que la réduction des émissions de plus de 1% par an
avait été associée à des récessions ou des bouleversements économiques.
C'est un vrai défi sur le plan de la croissance économique.
Car si nous avons des infrastructures qui consomment beaucoup de carbone,
et qu'il y a croissance économique,
il y aura aussi une hausse des émissions.
Je voudrais citer un article
que Kevin Anderson et moi avons écrit en 2011
dans lequel nous affirmons que pour éviter ce dangereux réchauffement de 2°C,
la croissance économique doit laisser place, au moins temporairement,
à une période d'austérité programmée dans les pays riches.
C'est un message très difficile à faire passer,
car il suggère que nous devons vraiment faire les choses différemment.
Il ne s'agit pas seulement de changement progressif.
Il s'agit de faire les choses différemment et de changer l'ensemble du système,
et il s'agit parfois de faire moins.
Et cela concerne chacun d'entre nous,
quelle que soit notre sphère d'influence.
Cela inclut le fait d'écrire à notre élu local,
de parler à notre patron, d'être son propre patron,
de parler à nos amis et notre famille,
ou simplement de changer notre mode de vie.
Nous avons besoin d'un véritable changement.
Pour l'heure, nous choisissons un scénario de 4°C.
Si nous voulons vraiment éviter le scénario de 2°C,
c'est le moment ou jamais de passer à l'action.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Alice, en fin de compte, vous dites
que si les pays riches ne commencent pas à réduire leurs émissions
de 10% par an immédiatement, et pas en 2020 ou 2025,
nous nous dirigerons droit vers le scénario de 4°C.
Quel est votre sentiment sur une réduction de 70% des émissions d'ici à 2070 ?
Alice Bows-Larkin : Oui, c'est loin d'être suffisant pour éviter les 2°C.
Ce qui se passe souvent,
c'est que les études de modélisation
qui s'intéressent à ce que nous devons faire
ont tendance à surestimer la vitesse à laquelle les autres pays du monde
peuvent commencer à réduire les émissions.
Les chercheurs font donc de grandes déclarations à ce sujet.
Mais ce qui compte vraiment, ce sont les émissions cumulées,
à court terme.
Il y a là une grande différence.
Si un grand pays comme la Chine, par exemple,
continue dans la même voie, même pour quelques années,
la différence sera énorme
quand viendra le moment de réduire nos émissions.
On ne peut même pas dire quand ça arrivera,
parce que tout cela dépend de ce que l'on fait à court terme.
Nous avons un champ d'action immense
et que nous n'utilisons pas ces leviers
qui permettent de réduire la demande énergétique. C'est dommage.
BG : Merci d'être venue partager ces informations.
ABL : Merci.
(Applaudissements)